dieser film ist so könnte man es
ausdrücken wirklich ein zynisches
brandmal was diese berlinale hier
hinterlässt
das ist in den letzten jahren zum
synonym für provokationen und skandal
geworden
dieses megalomane immersion projektes
russischen film asiya krzyzanowski der
in der ukraine ein riesiges filmset
gebaut hat was das forschungslabor des
sowjetischen albert einstein landau
daher da auch nachstellt und in der
ursprünglichen absicht einen film zu
drehen hatte er sich dann in dieses
filmset so sehr verliebt hat es immer
weiter ausgearbeitet dass er eigentlich
das interesse erst mal einen film
verloren hat und ein riesiges experiment
ein massives also durchdringendes
realität und fiktion durchdringendes
experiment gestartet hat mit insgesamt
400 laiendarstellern die er dort
gestartet gecastet hat die dort gelebt
haben über lange zeit und mehr oder
weniger sich hinein versetzt haben
lassen indem sie jetzt schon alltag der
30er jahre bis hin zu 1968
[Musik]
dieses riesige menschenexperiment wenn
man so will wurde permanent big brother
haft gefilmt und aus diesen über 700
stündigen filmmaterial sind jetzt viele
filme entstanden 13 verschiedene filme
serien also ein riesenprojekt bei der
berlinale im wettbewerb war jetzt
erstmals ein zweieinhalbstündiger film
aus dieser riesen gegen risiken serie zu
sehen
natascha heißt dieses material ein film
will ich eigentlich nicht nennen denn
was sieht man man sieht so genannte
realität
es gibt keinerlei drehbuch sondern es
gibt improvisierende laiendarsteller
teilnehmer alles dreht sich so ein
bisschen um eine kantine kellnerin
natascha die also gefilmt wird in ihrem
alltag wie sie mit wissenschaftlern die
an diesem forschungsinstitut zu besuch
kommen zusammen kommen sie mit ihnen
feiert wie sie wie sie sich streitet wie
sie mit einem von ihnen ins bett geht
sehr explizit wird das gezeigt und bis
dahin kann man sagen ist das eine mehr
oder weniger langweilige hin und wieder
auch interessante art und weise soziale
historische hyper korrektheit walten zu
lassen sich hinein zu versetzen und eben
die die alltäglichkeit zu formulieren
dann gibt es einen der wenigen schritte
in diesen in diesem material ansammlung
und man begleitet die natascha zu einem
verhör
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und dann passiert etwas wo man wirklich
sagen muss dass ein schockiert mit
welcher gleichgültigkeit die kamera
dabei gleich natascha wird von diesem
kaliber offizier in eine zelle geführt
wird brutal geohrfeigt in ihr werden die
kleider und entrissen und sie wird
schlussendlich gezwungen dazu eine
wasserwelle eine eine flasche in den
intimbereich sich einzuführen also eine
misshandlung situation eine folter
situation wird der real wieder gegeben
dort noch mal ist es handle sich nicht
um eine schauspielerische situation es
gibt kein sex sondern es ist realität
gewesen dieses schauspiel und wusste
nicht was passiert das merkt man auch
ganz deutlich in ihrer reaktion auf
dieses auf diesen befehl dieses tier
köpfigen kgb offiziers der in der mann
gesagt auch wirklich ein kgb offizier
war in seinem früheren leben also diese
foltermethode so zu sein als der
realität hier wiedergibt und in der
reaktion der natascha hat eine
teilnehmerin merkt man eben was für eine
furcht und angst sie hat in der
situation und darauf erhält die kamera
und man sieht dass in quälend langen
sekunden und man sitzt dort und will
eigentlich das kino sofort verlassen
wenn manch ein kritiker ist er das bis
zum ende durchhalten muss um ein urteil
fällen zu können dann hätte man das auch
sicher getan
es ist etwas an diesem film was einen
umtreibt weil er auf zynische auf
geradezu widerwärtige weise einen
voyeurismus bediente der angeblich
unsere zeit eingeschrieben ist nämlich
die vorstellung dass unsere blicke unser
schauen so abgestumpft ist durch die
digitalen bilderfluten die wir um uns
haben dass uns kein bild mehr wirklich
schockieren nicht mehr wirklich bewegen
kann
was hier gemacht wird ist nicht das
filmen von inhumanität soll es sein
inhumanes filmen die man hierbei und
eine eine grundsätzliche
broich licher umgang mit dem medium film
würde ich sagen
mit dem was kunst eigentlich ausmacht
nämlich das verstellen dass spielen das
austesten von von unterschiedlichen
möglichkeiten unter diesem war
juristischen annahme dass uns etwas
wirklich erscheinen soll wird hier
missbrauch getrieben so anders kann man
es nicht sagen und die schauspielerin
die man hier betrachteten der tasche die
wird man nicht vergessen diesen ausdruck
auf ihrem gesicht wenn sie diese diese
widerwärtige szene vollführen muss sie
spielt sich die vollführt sie sie führt
aus was ihr befehl befohlen wird diese
szene verfolgt ein und lässt ein
widerwärtig das erscheinen dieser film
ist so könnte man es ausdrücken wirklich
ein zynisches brandmal was diese
berlinale hier hinterlässt mit ganz
großer mit ganz großen zynismus er führt
er uns vor der wir angeblich geworden
sind wie wir auf gewalt und tod an die
totalitäre strukturen schauen am ende
beweist dieser film war eigentlich nur
eins nämlich einen totalitären regisseur
[Musik]